our next award goes to a cameraman and a
pilot who founded the hub care they
developed a turbine powered mini
helicopter named the heli cam known for
providing spectacular aerial photography
hover cam has contained to improve their
series of hella cams over the last two
decades the latest helicam system can
achieve shots that are virtually
impossible for full-size helicopters for
the continuing development of the
helicam the Academy is pleased to
present a technical achievement award to
Gifford Hooper and Philip George of
hover cam gentlemen would you please
join us on stage um thank you I'm just
like to say thank you to the Academy for
giving us this would gobsmacked amazed i
just like to say thank you to all the
people that's worked for us over the
years and in hover cam and people that
started right in beginning when he first
started a helicopter business people at
jeff bell who's a pilot at the time then
Phil end up being pilot and working in
and be joined together in home cam I'd
say thanks to and to my two girls for
putting up with me for so long going out
in film shoots and I'd like to say thank
you to the person now that has to put up
as me so fierce but was me going on film
shoots from going on film shoots again
um just thank you yeah it's been a long
road but it's great you know like I
wouldn't be here today if it wasn't for
our crew so like to thank Mike Bailey
there Marcus is with us here this
evening couple of behind that we haven't
been able to come out tonight that'll be
Nick and CJ part of the crew couldn't do
it without them thanks very much